Apple's iPhone 16 lineup is in the works
and we just got a major leak that
confirms a bunch of new details about
which Apple silicon chips are going into
each iPhone model next year as well as
the actual performance we should expect
from each chip which I'm going to
calculate in this video based on what
the new leaks are telling us but before
I get into the major leak that just
happened I want to quickly walk through
the history of leaks that we have for
these new Chips to lay the ground work
before we get into the performance
discussion back in October it was
confirmed that tsmc the company that
manufactures all of Apple's chips has
already started production of the second
generation n3e 3 nanometer chip
technology which is supposed to be more
energy efficient than the current n3b
that apple is using for the a17 pro chip
now back in September Jeff Pooh claimed
that the regular iPhone 16 and 16 plus
models would come with an enhanced a 17
chip with an upgrade to 8 GB of memory
but on October 19th he updated his
report to instead say that those new
iPhone models will come with the a18
chip confirming that Apple will no
longer be giving the regular iPhones the
previous gen chip which is great news he
even outlined his specific expectations
to say that the 16 Pro Models will be
using the a18 pro chip which makes
perfect sense because they're using the
pro branding on the current 15 Pro
Models and just a couple of days ago we
got the major leak that we're going to
focus on in this video which does sound
a bit confusing at first but I'll
explain what everything means according
to Mac rumor sources early development
versions of iOS 18 have already leaked
and there is specific code that points
to the actual chip Hardware that's
coming to the new iPhones specifically
we have the code names d47 and d48 for
the regular iPhone 16 models and then
d93 and d94 for the Pro Models but as
far as the chip the leaked code revealed
that the entire iPhone 16 range will use
a new chip code named toiti with the
identifier
t840 which is what Apple calls the a18
chip internally now the weird thing is
that this identifier references all four
of the models including the Pro Models
which doesn't really make sense because
we're expecting the Pro Models to get
the a18 pro chip and not the regular a18
so let me explain what's going on here
the most logical explanation that makes
sense from a technological and
economical point of view is that the a18
and a18 pro are actually the same
physical chip using essentially the same
design they'll both have 8 GB of RAM as
rumored but since it gets packaged on
top of the chip after the fact Apple can
actually use faster and newer Ram or
memory on the pro model chip if they
want to do that while saving money on
the regular a18 version by using the
previous generation memory on top of
that Apple can actually disable cores
within the same physical chip to
differentiate the a18 from the a18 pro
and to prove that we actually have the
a15 chip from a couple of years ago
which came in two different variants the
a15 that went into the regular iPhone 14
models came with a four core GPU while
the a15 that went into the Pro Models
came with a five core GPU but behind the
scenes they were actually the same
physical chip with a single GPU core
disabled on the regular iPhone 14 models
which was basically a process called
chip binning allowing o Apple to still
use and sell chips that had
manufacturing flaws within a GPU core
instead of having to toss the entire
chip and waste their money and the
reason this is so important for the a18
and a18 pro chips is because tsmc's
latest 3 nmet chip technology is known
to have yield issues so using this
method of disabling fla cores on the
regular a18 chip will help apple have
more usable chips to sell so what
exactly will the core layout look like
on both the a18 and the a18 pro and how
will they perform well it starts with
the brand new M3 Pro chip because For
the First time ever that specific chip
came with the CPU cluster of six
efficiency cores which was completely
random and didn't make sense at all
because both the regular M3 and M3 Max
chips had a 4 EC cor cluster just like
the previous M1 and M2 family of chips
so what if this seemingly random 6 ecor
cluster is actually borrowed from the
design of the upcoming a18 chip being
combined with two performance cores
making the first 8 core iPhone chip ever
this is actually a really big deal
because Apple's been using a six core
layout ever since the a11 chip that went
into the iPhone 10 in 20 2017 so it
might not seem like their performance
will improve by that much on the a18
chip but it's still 33% more ecores than
on the A7 Pro which will help boost
multi-core performance while allowing
the ecores to handle more tasks instead
of giving that workload to the two
performance cores which will help boost
efficiency and battery life so with that
said what kind of performance jump
should we expect from the new a18 and a
18 Pro chips well first of all starting
with single core performance both chips
will have the same performance cores
running at the same clock speed so there
will be no difference between the two
now Apple has recently had a tendency to
match the clock speed of new generation
a chips to the previous generation M
chips for example the A14 chip released
in 2020 had a 3.0 GHz clock speed while
the M1 released least 1 month later had
a 3.2 GHz clock speed then in 2021 the
new a15 chip came in with a matching 3.2
GHz clock speed the M2 Chip later came
with a 3.5 GHz clock speed in the summer
of 2022 right before the a16 chip came
in September with the same 3.5 GHz speed
and then later the a17 pro came with a
3.8 GHz clock speed which almost
perfectly matches the 3.7 on the M2 Max
and the M2 Ultra chips and now we have
the new M3 family of chips clocking in
at 4.1 GHz so I'm fully expecting both
of the new a18 Chips next year to match
that yet again so we should expect
around 3,100 points in geekbench 6's
single core Benchmark now in terms of
multi-core performance there's
definitely going to be a difference
between the a18 and the a18 pro seeing
as the regular a18 is likely to have two
of the ecores disabled for the same six
core layout as the previous A7 Pro so as
far as the multi-core performance the
a18 ship is likely going to be a little
bit faster than the a77 pro due to the
two performance cores being clocked
higher but I don't think they're going
to clock the ecores any higher so
there's not going to be any gains from
that but Apple being Apple will of
course compare the new base a18 ship to
the old a16 in the previous regular
iPhone 15 models so it'll still look
like a huge upgrade and then on the new
A8 Pro that chip will have the advantage
of higher clock speed on the two
performance cores and the extra two
efficiency cores so we should have a
bigger difference here to make it look
impressive over the previous A7 Pro chip
that they're going to compare it to and
then finally we have the GPU core layout
and I believe Apple can easily give the
a18 pro chip a six core GPU like what's
in the A7 Pro while disabling one of
those GPU cores for the regular a18 to
give it a 5 Core GPU just like we have
on the previous a16 chip but I'm not
expecting a major Improvement on the GPU
side since the only likely difference is
going to be a clock speed boost while
using the same number of relative GPU
cores so maybe about 15 to 20% faster
and that's it so with that said
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did you can subscribe above for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next
[Music]
one